[Musique]
c'est la génération basket les
chaussures dans les collèges ils en sont
fous
c'est un certain style une mode du monde
amérique tout le monde n 111 il
la sophistication des bottes et des
chaussures j'en ai quatre paires ouais
mais
savoir se limiter à 2 c a coûté une
petite fortune
tu sais combien ça coûte coin vers les
sachants 86 ans dans ce magasin
spécialisé les prix s'échelonnent de 200
à 1000 francs mais pour les marques
américaines les plus prisées rien à
moins de 400 francs
championne des ventes dans le haut de
gamme les baskets à air ou à fond ce
sont les plus chers mais elles se
vendent comme des petits pains ici
plusieurs centaines de terre par semaine
les enfants viennent traîtresse m'en
faire du repérage en magasin repérer
donc les modèles haut de gamme qui les
intéressent les modèles de leur idole et
vont ensuite faire la répercussion
auprès des parents disant d'un mandat
mans et une fois absolument se produit
ils reviennent en magasins ensemble
étalent leurs parents à tel point que
toute façon les parents craquent les
trouve ça très bien puis faut bien
qu'ils s'intéressent à quelque chose
donc mieux vaut s'intéresser à ça que
c'est pas des trucs fusil view sur le
plan du privé là par exemple cette
heure-là il m'a proposé une
participation
donc j'ai pas dit non les médecins non
plus ne disent pas non à condition de
prendre certaines précautions
sinon gare aux entorses il faut que les
lacets soit attaché parce que s'ils sont
détachés bien l'avouer la chaussure ne
joue plus son rôle
par ailleurs chez le jeune enfant et
bien les chaussures à tige montante
peuvent éventuellement être un petit peu
trop lourde et là il faut essayer de
trouver la chaussure qui soit bien
adapté à l'enfant pour qu'il garde une
bonne maîtrise de son geste
en gros à partir de 13 ans il ya plus de
problème il y à d'autres chaussures de
streetball de tennis des trainings
jogging trois à quatre fois moins cher
mais pour les enfants aucun intérêt
puisque elle n'évoque en rien les stars
du basket américain auquel ils veulent
te ressembler vrai qu'on s'arrête avant
d'avoir les résultats de roland garros
sur un phénomène de plus en plus
marquant c'est la vague extraordinaire
des chaussures de sport utilisé non pas
pour le sport mais pour les porter en
ville sachez que le troisième salaire de
patron aux états unis et celui de la
firme anglaise mais dirigée par un
américain reebok aymar du chatenet
devant des baskets c'est des chaussures
de foot quoi ou de marche où elles ont
rien d'extraordinaire sont plutôt pourri
et il ya des converse all star des vans
et des chaussures à 200 francs c'est
chaussures en toile qui valent rien du
tout vous emporter deux paires en même
temps le ballon c'est de là on a fait un
échange ale alors que vous échangez quoi
contre quoi bon nom là aussi lui sait
pas et portela mille hélas en dessous ça
fait une énorme boule c'est assez
ignoble lui dicter basket son nul à
wayne mais il fait ce qu'il veut
moi personnellement les baskets rouges
bon non je trouve ça sympa mais bon sans
plus ça c'est des chaussures en cuir des
converse alors en bas envoient deux
petits trous c2c une mousse qui amortit
les chocs c'est à dire que si on marche
sur un caillou ne sentira pas et à la
mortier quand on retombe quand on joue
au basket
le pied sentir à rien qu'est ce que vous
en pensez de ces chaussures bah moi je
trouve que c'est des chaussures de plage
quoi que ce soit et non mais que ça
choque genre après ski voilà genre
après-ski chaussures de ski à compost
commencent à se parler
tout le monde peut être à la mode quoi
est ce qu'ils peuvent passer achetés
sont obligés de voler tuer quoi moi je
suis habitué je me suis déjà fait voler
des choses
événement monté grossetti fin mai 10h
je dis ça il a combien de chaussures il
en a pour 700 mal à 800 balles et femmes
et 10 pour ses tantes en quoi je dire à
faire connaître et reconnaître la de la
phase ii des gens normal on les voit
arriver ça vous convient c'est là je les
ai payées en 300 balles pour son franc
parler
mais combien de paires j'en ai 3 900
balkans même nom mais les autres j'ai dû
payer plus cher ouais il ya une paire
que j'ai pays quatre enfants c'est là je
les ai payés 300 francs c'est trop cher
non oui c'est assez cher pour toi cher
ne vais pas me laisser faire pitié
[Musique]